[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum how's it going she
have a good week and I guess it was the
weekend
sometimes it feels like every day's the
weekend doesn't it also if you could
please follow us on all our social
medias and subscribe to the show
wherever your listening or watching that
really helps you know we can watch on
YouTube Ryan makes these amazing videos
so you can watch the interviews there or
listen on Spotify please subscribe write
a review and you gave us a five star
rating I mean a 7,000 ratings ever it's
pretty badass
so make sure you handle us and handle us
it's getting a little perverted I've
been doing those Instagram lives if
you've joined us we had Zack Levi came
on the other night and it was awesome we
talked about you know therapy and
anxiety and life and it was really great
it was really fun if you get to see any
clip of that on my Instagram live I know
some people taped it but um sometimes
they have special guests pop up but the
most interesting thing is really on
those Instagram lives that people want
to be invited to be on the video so you
can split the screen with them and so I
randomly invite people to come on the
Instagram lives and they have been
unbelievable we're gonna do patron stuff
at the at the end my shoutouts to my
lovely patrons who I love for the inside
and also the patreon the horror patron
that I'm doing with Jon Heder
Napoleon Dynamite you know we're doing a
horror patreon exclusive it's only there
it's called the where have all the good
horror movies gone where if you movies
but we also talked and comment to each
other and then and the patrons and it's
actually really a lot of fun and thank
you Bryce for your editing in Europe and
by the way we message when you get
messages from us on the patreon it's us
more importantly the great charities out
there that I love Ronald McDonald House
reminding you Tom Welling Kristin Kreuk
and myself we did a amazed calm slash
reunion you donate for the Ronald
McDonald House of Los Angeles that I've
been a part of for a long time and they
draw somebody and you get to have a
virtual room with us with and just talk
to us for a long time so that's fun also
throwing out food on foot org helping
home
Simon $98 club member love that place
and a lot of my listeners fans patrons
you unbelievably kind have I've heard
from Rob and and the head of the
organization food on foot they dude your
your people from your podcast your
listeners are like donating money on my
college just too much don't get me
started you don't even get emotional
really quick I want to support the
animal rescue mission arm my good friend
Shira who I love and adore she is part
of that organization she she heads it
and go to their website it's really
incredible tell Michael Rosenbaum Sencha
are you listening to the inside of your
podcast WWE animal rescue mission org I
also was on Instagram today I said what
the hell man so I I'm thinking of
auctioning some old scripts that I have
signed I have many of different things
cuz I'm kind of a dork like that you
guys know Tom Welling he didn't eat
increased and they didn't they didn't
take anything home with them but I took
wardrobe and things something I got
raise some money so maybe a few scripts
a few articles of clothing whatever I
was on Instagram so I might dumb auction
those off for charity whatever you get a
hundred bucks 500 bucks thousand bucks
you give it to charity every every cent
counts so it's good also go to inside of
you online store we got inside you mugs
inside of you tons of stuff but new
shirts and hoodies and all that stuff
just came in and they're selling like
hotcakes so go to the inside EU online
store and I'm doing a stage it people
have been asking me to do stage at
having done one and have everyone done
done one alone that's tomorrow May 27th
at 6 p.m. California time that's
specific that's Wednesday tomorrow it's
a stage it with my good dear friend he's
really the only person I've seen Rob
Danson he's in the band left on Laurel
we did that together and but he and I
have been you know hanging out he wears
a mask he's ten feet away so we're being
safe and he will join me for a stage it
and what prizes and all that so go to
stage calm look for I think that the
subject is Rosenbaum and Danson da NSO n
so check that out you know I appreciate
you guys this week it's a great guest
people have talked to me on the you know
listeners have written in the fans and
I'm gonna read some letters on the outro
of the show when when our guest is gone
but they're like you know it's talk
about mental health talk about all these
things why don't you have a doctor on or
something like that or a therapist so
that's what we did so in the past couple
weeks I've interviewed my some
therapists a life coach this week so
that's gonna happen we're gonna have a
mental health we're figuring all that
out now but already recorded and
fantastic but this week this was amazing
this is someone that I've known for a
while I haven't known like we're not
buddies in fact he doesn't really return
my emails all the time cuz he's he's a
doctor he's busy okay so you know it's
not like I constantly braid the guy but
no he's he's a fantastic man he's got a
heart of gold he helps a lot of people
for free
you've known on Celebrity Rehab he's uh
what else I mean there's so many
podcasts Loveline he's got he was on The
Masked what is it the masked man the
masked crusader I don't know I don't
want [ __ ] that he was on it I love him
and he has so much insight today you're
gonna love him too and that's dr. drew
dr. Drew Pinsky so why don't we get
inside of dr. drew it's my
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
how you doing dr. drew very sir I'm good
you look like you're go about two either
you got off work or you're about to go
to a an event I do kind of an event I've
got the I do a show on FOX 11 every
night so I got to suit up for that and I
got a blow out of here right afterwards
all right this is one of the reasons I
want to have you not only for this but I
just can't I just can't imagine anybody
doing more than you I don't know how
you're not divorced I don't know you're
how you're not in Celebrity Rehab so
this it's a great question I mean when I
was really bad I mean my workaholism
it's so funny bring this up I had a
dream about it last night but and my
daughter was sort of confronting me
about my workaholism in my dream
but in my you know in the 90s I don't
know how my wife tolerated it I don't
know I I would get up at 5 in the
morning and I would struggle to get home
by 10:00 at night every day and I mean
everyday and so and that went on for
years did you make promises to were like
this is gonna end this is just how it is
now and then it got worse probably that
kind of thing or it just this is this
way I have to do this is you know other
people are sick I they you know I don't
know I don't know when how I how I
persuaded her that it was the right way
to be but it took me to carve it down to
I mean I carve it down but you have four
podcasts is that right you know but now
I'm not bad I'm really not bad compared
to how it was this is like leisurely I I
didn't never I never ate a meal sitting
down I never got more than six hours of
sleep and it was just it was insane and
the people would go off all night back
in the days of the beeper and I would
still run in the middle of the night at
least two nights a week it was crazy it
was super duper and you still have a
practice in Pasadena I put it small I
mean it's patience I've fallen for
thirty years you know people I know
really really well III was doing
telemedicine before it became a thing
this because I can manage my patients I
mean I know them so well so I can manage
them and how many do you have how many
regular patients that you've had for all
the
years uh missed a few hundred you know
[ __ ] three four hundreds in like that
three or four hundred he's in a few I
was up way up for a long time I mean I
was doing a full-time Hospital practice
and and working a psychiatric hospital
and seeing 25 outpatients a day and it
was it was nothing do they ever say
things to you like you know I'm sure
you're busy with your celebrity friends
or your celebrity patients but no the
ones that have been me they've been with
me forever and when all that stuff
started happening they were like hey
anyway not about my back so this they
they they got that there was two worlds
I lived it and what kind of medicine is
that like is it just everything they
come to you with everything and you kind
of instruct them to go you need to go
see this doctor or this specialist every
non-surgical and I used to do a lot of
critical care you know so ventilator
management that stuff you starting to
hear about these days and the coat day
of kovat I used to do a lot of that
stuff and so I actually signed up to go
to New York because I guess I I didn't
know but I guess the younger internist
aren't being trained to do intensive
care medicine they've left that now for
the intensivists
and so I when Governor Cuomo called out
for volunteer as I said in a minute
sign me up I can come and work on the
frontlines no problem and you've done
that already
well I signed up and I went through the
interview process and they just said
stand by and they never called me but I
would have done it happily I mean I
really was looking for and what would
that job entail what exactly would it be
it would be a lot of work it would have
been admitting people into an intensive
care unit it probably been I don't know
if I would been managing the whole unit
or do a shift on the unit or be there
with other doctors managing the unit I
don't know it depends on the hospital
but it would have been you know our our
care pretty quick care of critically ill
patients again I did I was gonna be a
cardiologist and that got sidetracked
because I started moonlighting right
after I finished my internship I started
moonlighting in a psychiatric hospital
down the street and I became completely
intrigued by what was going on there and
I was initially and for you for the
first like
five seven years I was there I was
running the medical services so I became
really good in the medical management of
psychiatric patients and guess where a
lot of the medical problems were they
were down on the drug unit so then I got
interested in that population and how to
get people off drugs even though I'd
worked in a County Hospital for you know
15 years well 10 years never anybody had
given me any guidance on on drug
withdrawal and how that could be a
discipline and there was a guy there at
the time this is this is like 1980 1986
and there was a guy there that had made
a clinical discipline out of drug
withdrawal and I learned that learn how
to do that and then I started I got
pretty good at it and then people are
asking me to see more and more of these
drug addicts who else who had lots of
medical problems and the whole while I
was so [ __ ] hubris t'k I was like go
what goes on in those rooms was twelve
step on the wallets and what is that
nonsense they love steps I do real
medicine and and I watched some people
go young healthy people go from dying to
amazing over the course of like three
months and I was just like what is that
what is happening no I need to
understand more about that and that's
kind of how I got into it I mean you got
into I mean your father was a doctor
right yep and were you captivated by
what he did as a as a youngster - dude I
think I I delight him in some fashion I
always just assumed that's what I would
do
I hit Amherst College in 1976 and you
know ran straight into winter there and
the level of competition intellectually
there was insane and after a semester of
doing pretty well but I just tapped out
like I can't do this I'm not meant for
this see these there are really smart
people here those guys get to do this
this isn't for me
and I spent about a year and a half
screwing around doing music and theater
and
saying yeah yeah did you see me on the
Med singer well that's why I was I was
gonna ask you I mean I mean I mean did
you want to be a performer did you want
to be a for about five minutes I thought
about going to West Germany and really
training seriously in Opera because I
was pretty good I could create a pretty
good sound and I was you know decent at
classical music but I was you know thank
God I did not do that because I am a
terrible musician and I have a son who's
a really well-trained classical singer
and pianist and he's the real deal I was
not even a dilettante do you sing
together come on doesn't he plenty
little Jim Croce or a little uh no he's
classmate rain so we could maybe doesn't
know Jim Croce into the second act of a
fellow or something and do a duet but
but
so I wisely yeah and I got very
depressed very depressed and during that
period and started having panic attacks
and just I was a wreck and and I was a
little time going well that medicine
thing that's what they you want me to do
I'm not that I don't know well I'm gonna
find my old way bla bla bla and then
finally after about a year and a half of
that nonsense I had the courage to go
got pretty good at science and I wonder
if I went back to that and it
immediately felt better I immediately
thought oh oh there's something there
and started working my way back and then
I had to get my act together fast
because now it's my junior year in
college I've got one semester of pre-med
under my belt
and I've got to go to school full-time I
got a kick ass and everything I've got
to say you know multiple science classes
which was considered death at my college
he's didn't do it but I did it and made
it through what is that what is that
like joy because I never had that try
maybe with certain things but I mean it
just seems so overwhelming some so
daunting to imagine him to become a
doctor the things you have to do you
have to really want to become a doctor
to go through that yeah yeah which I
when I was a when I was a freshman in
college would have been terrible if I'd
done it when I returned to a junior I
was on I was like and there's something
about the male brain my brain was not
mature enough to sit and do the work
that needed to happen when I was 9 I was
18 when I got to college but at nine to
nineteen twenty well now I could do it I
could suddenly do it it was real and and
I could kind of excel at it and ended
and I was I was into it I was very very
very into it so you love to work you
love being around people who love to
work I just love science and I love the
rigor of the training and and I was a
very well trained scientist by the end
actually and then when I got to medical
school I remember we would have we would
have gross anatomy at the end of the day
every day
and I would get out of that anatomy lab
but my core would always be on the roof
for this parking lot I would just walk I
just go oh my god I'm so happy to be on
time I feel like I've such purpose I
feel like this is so meaningful I'm so
delighted to do and so it was just
gratitude all the way across now by the
time I got into the wards and third and
fourth year I got a little less Oh
moreover well that's when I sort of
workaholism kicked in and stuff my
codependency so the residents would like
kick the [ __ ] out of me
for years and then when I got back
around to residency then I was into it
again I was back really really really I
mean you just ever think and you
probably I see this is the thing with
science is that it's always changing and
there's always things to learn it's
almost like being a technician or
somebody who's with the internet [ __ ] in
it and analogically speaking you have to
keep up to date with editors that's
overwhelming for me even to think about
I think pilots have to keep up to date
on the you know the aircraft and what's
going on and make sure their judgment is
good and I don't know somehow piloting
an aircraft to me feels about the same
and yeah I can tell you this is two
aspects to this keeping up part one is
well there's actual testing you should
be doing every year and I do this thing
called the MKS ap every year I've done
it for
the years you have to or you do it it's
a way of keeping your medical education
sort of at the top level it's just a cry
you know you don't have to but I do it
do you think a lot of doctors do that a
lot of guys do a lot of guys girls do
but but but I I don't know if it's a
minority or not it's probably a minority
but but there are there's people that do
it you know and I'm one of them
I've no trouble keeping up on the
reading because I like it I'm into it I
read the three journals a week but
that's that's kind of easy that part the
the more meaningful part is what you get
from your peers this is the part that
people don't appreciate that you have to
be interacting with your peers to know
what what's happening right now you have
to be talking to the specialist you have
to be hearing from the other kind of
because there's the sub specialist in
medicine you know the cardiologist
against neurologists the neurologist
they're the ones that sort of set the
practice and what and what they're doing
you have to be interacting with because
they're they're the ones moving things
along all the time and we his internal
medicine kind of come along with them
yeah so you know
good good peers and their practices sort
of set the tone for what we do and then
you then I go oh yeah I was reading
about that I get what he's doing or he
or she is doing
there's the practice of that I'm seeing
it in my patient right now and I will
attempt that do you see guys that are
relatively bright but you like this guy
should never become a doctor and you're
there they're there with you they're
graduating with you whatever the case
but you're like that that kind of person
usually finds their way into a field
where they don't have to care you know I
mean there's fields of medicine like
pathology or certain things work and
your caretaking is you know you you're
just a technician at certain points you
know you just need to do a great job and
that's all they want to do they want to
be a resurgent or they want to be a
great pathologist wherever it is they
they don't have to it's better when they
care but they don't have to care all
right right yeah so yeah I don't mind
those I thought those guys because I
need these technicians that can really
you know when I had my prostate out I
just asked the guy what's what's
complication rate
1100 complication rate zero ago fine
let's go now is it was that 2013 it
allows diagnosed eleven years ago right
yes it was thirteen
yeah so what what happens I mean that's
that's something we just touch on you
know trying to give the audience a
little information here and they
probably should know this but a lot of
people don't like you should get your
prostate checked every year right and
it's blended by the way is blood enough
because a lot of doctors say oh just
check your PSA level or do you need not
to be rude but do you need a finger in
your ass it's it's every year after 50
for all men unless you have a first
degree relative with prostate cancer and
then it which case it is every year
after 40 and so you recommend the blood
and the finger better lead for sure
finger why is the finger better not
better than blood it's just it's just
Colora he does such a thing as a low PSA
prostate cancer and and they're actually
really bad so there is such a thing
right and you would pull it and you
would feel it when you reach in there
you know I I hadn't gotten one I don't
act
Jony of the magical finger you know I
had only got gotten uh one last year
for the first time and I'm 48 years old
47 years old that's you know that's okay
grandfather my grandfather had it but he
got rid of it but yeah he did have it so
really not technically but but you could
argue she started 40 but definitely at
50 right and the colonoscopy I just had
one of those you know everybody said it
was that bad like I really didn't feel
that bad
I took the liquids I took him all at the
same time for the most part I didn't do
it the way you probably should and yeah
I I went pretty hard it was like liquid
fire for a couple hours
the preps are easier now nothing oh my
god I remember talking to doc and the
next thing I know is like all right I
don't see anything in there now people
when they get the polyps is that a
concern like when you have polyps and
they took them out that's that's the
concern well it changes how we screen
you and I'm a big advocate you know once
you have polyp you need a follow-up in
one to three years depending on what
kind of policy it is that sort of thing
but more than that I'm a big advocate of
genetic screening now so there are there
are syndromes of primarily how your DNA
repairs itself right your DNA is always
making mistakes I mean the biochemistry
of DNA replication is so complicated of
course they're going to be mistakes and
there's a whole system in your in your
cells of mistake repairs and some people
as repair systems aren't that great so
sometimes these these DNA errors get
through and that is a cancer or that's a
polyp and there are certain genetics
that you can test for to see what they
are one of those people and I always had
a hunch that I was because if colon
cancer my family and my dad mountains
left prostate cancer so I did this thing
called color comm which I recommend for
everybody see olor calm it's about 200
bucks they test you for the thirty
thirty five most common DNA I sort of
like brocco you know brocco genes well
this is about there's actually about
four hundred things like that but
there's thirty or thirty-five common
ones and i won i have something called
lynch syndrome i'm an MS h6 lynch which
puts me at risk for colon
prostate cancer and so now I have to get
an upward and lower endoscopy every year
because in that my sons had to start
there is at 25 because they had it -
yeah
I mean look it's important to just be on
top of it I look a lot of guys it's
always been like I don't go to the
doctor I don't go to that well then you
die pretty much you don't go to the
doctor you're gonna die have a lot of
friends that don't want to go the doctor
I'm fine I feel great third grade is not
the game the game is prevent getting
sick prevent the cancers pick them up
when they're early before they get away
you know it's it's about stays yeah get
on your blood pressure medicine stay on
your cluster you do these things that
make you live longer works right then we
longer than we're supposed to and it's
pharmacology and screening that helps us
do that well it's also the same thing
with you know going to psychiatrist go
into a therapist doing that you know it
thank God it's normalizing a little bit
where everyone's sort of talking about
it now or more people especially on my
show we talk about that and you know I
always say I'm not a doctor but you know
you should probably go see a therapist
but I talked to somebody knows what
they're talking about what for eleven
years you went to a therapist for 11
years
yeah best thing I ever did what years
with were these age of about 33 to 44
something like that so so I have an
anxiety disorder and I can tell you that
panic attacks and depression when I was
in college but I've generalized anxiety
I'm a little on the OCD spectrum and we
have triplets and during the early years
my anxiety was spinning my workaholism
was crazy you know how am I gonna how am
I gonna support through Triana I was
just I was nuts
then at the age of one one of our kids
needed brain surgery and I guess I spun
out like a top I wasn't aware of it but
my wife called me at work one day and
went you need to talk to a therapist and
I was like yeah yeah because I'd only
thought it would help me with my work
with the drug addicts except I was
starting to do that and yeah I'm
absolutely gonna go she listening
go uh it just might the hair stood up in
the back of my neck okay okay I hear you
yeah
down made the car started and it was
beyond wonderful oh well you know you
really need one person in your life I
always say that you just trust that
whatever that person says you are for
the most part are gonna take that advice
is Susan your wife that seems like it's
one person when she tells you something
no well in certain times but she when I
know she's serious that then she's
pretty serious yes I will take that
direction
the the kind of therapy I did though was
not advice oriented at all it was turned
out I had a weak connection the way I
conceptualize these things I so so the
primary sort of problem today that
people have is regulating their emotions
right called an effect regulation and I
had a particular issue where I was not
strongly connected to my primary
emotions so they were sort of vague and
I couldn't really feel them so I had to
get to do insight oriented deep what's
called a mostly focused therapy to try
to connect up those emotions and you
essentially do that by sitting with
another person in proximity when you
trust and just going I'm feeling
whatever it is and then that person
reflects back to you on their face and
with their voice an understanding of
your experience which is called a second
order representation that you then is
sort of a metabolized emotion that you
then take back in so it's primary motion
metabolized emotion internalized and
identified and connected emotion so if I
say dr. drew you ask me how I feel and
I'm feeling I feel sort of like tingly
like almost numb I feel like I'm anxious
it's in my chest I feel like I just feel
like I'm just I'm just anxious and I
don't know why and I just feel like I'm
ahead of myself and what's just just
tuned in like would I get to you're
anxious I get you're anxious what what
comes up what are you feeling what what
what else what else is there what's on
your mom what's like what pops into your
head right right and then and then
following that and so I've gotten very
good at doing that for other people too
because I've been the object of it
and for drug addicts that is a
particularly important thing to be able
to do because drug addicts are
disconnected from their emotions and and
get so lost in their disease they don't
know what's real and what's [ __ ] and
they want to know and when somebody else
can feel their feelings it's called you
know feeling felt when I can tune in to
what you know it's when I can receive
what's really going on with them it's an
important experience that's in a way
that makes them feel connected and safe
and secure and of course Trust is a big
issue for drug addict inside of you is
brought to you by Express VPN we all
know that expressvpn protects your
privacy and security but there's
something you might not know which is
even cooler than that you can use
Express VPN to unlock movies and shows
that are only available in other
countries right so with all the time on
our hands now or you know we're stuck at
home
what do we do you know we're gonna run
out run out of space or rounded things
to watch a Netflix oh you know this
whole week I've been using expressvpn to
watch Doctor Who I'm proud of that I've
been told to wash it and I'm using it
and it's pretty darn cool it's simple
even I could do it I just fire up the
expressvpn app change my location to the
UK refreshed efflux and that's it
expressvpn hides your IP address and
lets you control where you want sites to
think you're located you can choose from
almost a hundred different countries so
just think about all the Netflix
libraries you can go through but it's
not just Netflix you could use Express
VPN for Hulu BBC iPlayer YouTube NIT you
name it hundreds of VPNs out there and
the reason I use Express VPN is simply
because it's faster it's ridiculously
fast and that's important to me and
probably every person listening there's
never any buffering or lag you could
stream an HD no problem expressvpn is
also compatible with your devices all
your devices phones media consoles Smart
TVs and more you can watch what you want
on a personal device or on the big
screen wherever you are if you visit my
special link right now expressvpn
dot-com slash iou you can get an extra
three months of expressvpn for free
that's right support the show watch what
you want protect yourself with
expressvpn @ Express v P n com / io EU
inside view is brought to you by better
help online counseling this is something
I I love doing these spots these are
extraordinary times to say the least
with everything going on today I mean
the stress anxiousness the depression I
was irritable
earlier in the podcast all these things
better help offers online licensed
professional counselors who are trained
to listen and help so many folks are
using better help
in fact it's growing so quickly that
better help is hiring more therapists
that's how well it's doing better help
counselors specialize in many areas
relationship
treble anxiety family conflicts
depression loss trauma and much more is
it weird that I have had all those I
think we all suffer from things connect
with your counselor in a safe and
private online environment anything you
share is confidential and all you do
guys is you fill out a questionnaire to
help assess your needs and you get
matched with the counselor in less than
24 hours easy to schedule secure video
or phone sessions with your therapist
plus exchange unlimited messages if for
any reason you're unhappy with your
account sir
you can request a new one at any time no
additional charge professional help when
you want and wherever you want it get
started today folks go to better help
calm slash inside that's better h e LP
dot-com / inside talk to a therapist
online and get help it's amazing because
I look at you and I just see it's
somebody who has their [ __ ] together
somebody's always had their [ __ ]
together wow I wish I could emulate I
wish I could be aspired to be a dr. Drew
we all want to be but then I look and
then you used to talk about your anxiety
and your flaws and all these things
everyone's human in it if anything it
helps knowing that top doctors people
that really help other people get the
same thing that we do there are people
that are highly narcissistic that will
tell you that feelings don't matter for
them and good if they're a surgeon bad
if they're a psychiatrist or a
psychologist you know tubes and there's
a place for everything but you should
always be skeptical of people seem to
they're not connected to their emotions
emotions don't matter so you went to
therapy did he had anxiety you took did
you ever take xanax or on any of those
things
did it make things worse I was really
miss managing college people give me a
bunch of things it was all bad and it's
I think I was so badly mismanaged in
college that I think is what got me
interested in for a long while I was you
know I loved a lot of stuff I was
helping adolescents young adults and
that that I think that interest came for
the fact that there was no medical
services for adolescents and young adult
when I needed it I mean I really needed
it and I remember I went down
you know I the sense that these panic
attacks were psychologically a trick and
so I went to the mental health services
at the college which was in the bell
tower
fascinatingly in the belfry and they
sent me down to the medical doctor which
at that time was some retired guy you
know it's in New England some tired guys
serving his time there and he looks at
me he goes I need to get your act
together just take some long walks in
the woods or something and I'm like one
of Crucible that's gonna make me that's
good take care of this I'm feeling I
don't think so much I would happily know
and it was it was complete disgusting
mismanagement and I always thought oh
man I got to make sure that this doesn't
happen to anybody else
so mismanagement like you were doing too
many things you had some kind of
structure in a way but there were those
issues found lee depressed and I was
having disabling panic attacks and there
was pharmacology available at the time
that could have helped me there was of
course psychotherapies and things that
could have helped me and to have a a
family practitioner and look at me and
go get your act together boy it was
destructive it was just terrible and
then I had one therapist who was no good
and then finally I found a good one and
kind of got me through it a bit but I
still struggled for a while I don't see
any what you just said right there is
very important because you know people
looking for a good therapist they think
okay I meet a therapist I guess I should
just stay with him thinking oh well
therapists or therapists they're not if
you don't like them if you're not
feeling comfortable if you don't feel
like opening up you probably should look
for another therapist correct each just
like everything else that each have
their strengths and talents and and you
as a patient don't really know what you
need at the beginning it's hard to tell
sometimes I didn't the way I need it
when I was starting out I would say it's
a good bet generally here's his sort of
general principle these days trauma is
so common that you probably need some
trauma-informed therapy so somebody
who's got some specialization trauma is
usually helpful and secondly whatever
technique they're using does not matter
as much as their capacity for deep
empathy so you need to feel felt if that
person must be
laser beam focused on you and if you
feel if that focus is there that's all
you need you know what's weird I swear I
don't know what it was because I've had
male therapists for a long time and in
the last year I have female therapist
and for some reason I connect so I can
get emotional I'm like Who am I
it's I don't know what it is I'm not
saying that male therapists aren't good
I'm just saying for me having a female
presence I don't maybe have something to
do I'm sure you're thinking oh it
probably has issues with his mother
maybe but also I think women are better
at doing this kind of connecting they
just naturally can connect that way we
as men we struggle to do it and in each
of us and that doesn't diminish me the
power or the work of any male therapist
some of them are extremely good yeah but
I think women more easily do this than
the rest of us yeah and they are
maternal figures if they feel like
mothers to me when I talked to them they
did do something comfortable that was
what I and I didn't I didn't get what I
needed from my home and so a lot of the
work was finishing that work up you know
you go back to talking about how you
wanted to be a voice you're quoted here
you said my goal was always to be a part
of pop culture and relevant to young
people to interact with the people they
hold in high esteem that we gotta focus
this was the day of AIDS - and I know
one was talking to them about this it
was you know was Anthony found she that
motivated me to go on the radio you know
this know oh he was a big player in the
AIDS thing and I was working on dates
I was just deep in the AIDS epidemic and
and he was out there going you got young
doctors you gotta go educate you got a
contained behavior they're gonna be 10
million dead if we don't change their
behavior and so I took that very
seriously and I had an opportunity to go
on the radio and it's like oh then
that's talking to young people about
this this well we just had stopped
calling grids you were now calling AIDS
we had the a causative agent which at
that time we called htlv 3 if you
remember yeah turns darks had not been
coined yet no was no one was talking to
young people and it was considered
scandalous when I started to do it I
what why we have to change the behavior
I gotta good they're gonna get this
infection if we don't so it was a really
he was a big part of my motivation to go
in there and be talking about it but the
point was as it went a little time went
along that I would I I felt like I was
always trying to insert myself into the
cultural vehicles whatever they might be
so I could reach people particularly
young people and I always thought
because they're really on the trajector
establishing the trajectory of their
life and some small adjustments can you
know keep it heading towards you know
ionosphere as opposed to landing in the
ocean and and I just was fascinated with
that idea I just thought was an
important thing to do then I sort of
drifted off of that into addiction
generally and I sort of sort of continue
to see that as one of the major problems
of our time and that is young people and
adults now and still I tried to use
cultural vehicles to make a difference
that's that's the idea get-get in
crawling the stuff that may be
uncomfortable but it makes a difference
go ahead and do it hence like a love
line the level I was the original thing
but tents like a celebrity area yeah
which I watched all the time
I remember on Loveline you know I
remember being a guest in your shows
late at night it was I was doing so I
forgot what I was doing but I remember
asking you if a urinating helps after
sex if you you know if you don't get an
STD and I'm not sure it was the
brightest question in the world but I
still pee after sex is that smart it's
not gonna make much of a mail for women
it's it's smart because they can get
urinary tract infection so rule doesn't
prevent STD it prevents your a chronic
infections in women but can't guys get
UTIs that really throws are too long
with women urethra is are shortened
bacteria gets pushed up in with a
bladder very easily so only men should p
I should relax I don't need to go to the
bathroom
it's not a bad habit not a bad habit I
mean it cleans out the urethra and maybe
you know read some irritation right you
know I'm only bringing this up because
you know it's a news and and only
because I I commend you and I find it
really amazing how after the whole Koba
19 thing and I know you've heard
so much [ __ ] about it but you know in
the beginning when really nobody knew
anything you know your outlook was was
obviously way different than it is now
you're sort of perception it wasn't
really different I got to tell you that
now that we're here it's not way
different I when I look I talked to a
producer yesterday who is producing this
show in Denver that I was on four months
ago and I told him I said I feel now
exactly the way I did when I was
shooting my mouth off on your show which
is we don't know what's going on the
press needs to shut up everyone needs to
listen to foul Chi and the CDC they
should be your guiding star but the
press needs to shut up because they are
gonna create a panic and that panic is
gonna create god only knows what horrors
now here we are in the state of
California where we overshot in other
words where school is so good that the
the the esta the disease rate was about
200 times less than we predicted good
job maybe we could have navigated
through this and maybe been down by a
factor of 10 or a factor of five and not
had to have closed everything down the
way we did the CDC never recommended
that they never recommended it so I
stand by what I said which is the CDC is
your guiding light if you do more I
understand why the governor in
California did more right I feel bad for
him because that's a tough decision and
I stood behind him when he made it I
said look he's got a plan for the
worst-case scenario if his judgment is
that we need to shut it all down and get
a mercy ship in here and you know get
30,000 ventilators in here
his job is repaired for the worst-case
scenario I think it's a gross
overreaction but I said it at the time
but I will stand behind him because
that's that's a hard call yeah
retrospect it's easy to go hey man we
way way way overdid it we could have
done that we lighten things up now
because you know we've shown that okay
we've been flattened the curve and we
don't actually know scientifically when
the people talk about following the
science we actually do not know
whether or not lockdown
shelter in place is different or has a
different effect than wearing a mask and
social distancing and people are
conflating the word social distancing
social distancing does not include
shutting down businesses and sheltering
in place that's something the government
did and okay it worked but it worked so
well maybe you didn't need to do that
maybe there maybe it'll be just as good
if we wear eye masks and social distance
maybe I don't know I don't know but it's
worth a shot and then chase it and make
sure we you know really have enough
people lose the other thing the governor
is doing that's really good he's got a
whole army of people to chase a little
outbreaks and make sure those are
contained yeah the important so what do
you think scary you don't be a were cool
but what do you thinks gonna happen in
the next couple months is this gonna go
on for months and months and months the
part I didn't know about this virus is
clinically how it affects at-risk
population so people over 75 people with
essentially metabolic syndrome
hypercholesterolemia hypertension
central obesity SF I've now seen cases
and it is brutal it is awful and until
we come up with some treatments for that
I am very concerned about this illness
and it and the other thing it is more
contagious than the flu it's highly
contagious so those were those are the
two pieces that I have changed my
opinion on that it's it is more
contagious and and by the way the day
that Tony found cheese Anthony found she
said it's not the flu it's a more
contagious it's more deadly that was the
day I change my opinion and then I saw
some cases and now I'm you know see it
how awful it is but it when it's bad man
it is just until we find some treatments
for that which I think we're on the
verge of yeah we're very cautious with
this thing right demmas vir remember
what is it desert here is one thing but
I think there going to be some some
immune modulus or interventions that we
will understand how to use much better
very soon there may be monoclonal
antibodies we're starting to ramp up on
convalescence serum and by the way a
pitch for everybody give blood there's
all this focus on food there's a lot of
food around
have shortages of blood give blood that
saves lives well that's not something
you hear constantly like you have with
all this other stuff going on because I
mean I'm hearing news and it's changing
every day and this and don't do this and
this and but you don't hear enough give
blood we got a visa T is another one
risk factor for this thing and there's a
lot of food I'm glad people are taking
care of the food but the stuff that's
the focus on what we're really gonna
save lives in the very immediate
immediate term very immediate term which
is blood products if you've been I could
give convalescence serum if you haven't
go give blood you're not gonna catch it
by giving blood don't worry
yeah and what do you think about like
hanging out with your friends or maybe a
friend or two if you're wearing masks
and you're separated you his I mean
there's a lot of people who you know
look down on things what do you do at
this point like because you know if
people would get alone people want to
but they want to be respectful and then
there's some of those people those
idiots sorry that they are that I don't
have to wear a mask I'm like well if it
says no shoes no shirt no service why
can't we add a mask to that equation we
should and as we open up the only way
we're gonna be opening up successfully
is if we are diligent with the social
distancing and the mast but yeah if you
have a friend over and you're
particularly you're out of doors and
you're wearing a mask and you're better
than six feet apart maybe if you were
feeling early and nobody has a fever
that's probably safer than being in your
home oh I would say food delivery no
right but we've never compared lock down
that I know maybe somebody can show me
the data where it has been compared
[ __ ] my knowledge never compared lock
down versus social distancing and
wearing a mask they may be exactly the
same and I'm hoping they are but in
order for us to maintain the mask on
social distancing we have to do that
really diligently so I'm not and I'm not
in favor of these Yahoo's not wearing
masks you've got to do it we're gonna
all end up back you know who knows you
know how what they would how would they
would respond to the second layer one of
my celebrity friends said I'm not gonna
give his name people have no idea how
many people dr. drew helped for free
that's true I mean helping helping me
right now he's not ever that is not just
talking about on the radio or through
media
i I forty percent of the time I didn't
get paid for what I did treating drug
addicts and when I did get paid I easily
got paid a fraction or whatever should
be fing paid cuz it's just so I this if
you want to help drug addicts there's
not a lot of available real resources
do you still check in with the guys from
the Celebrity Rehab or
you know guys that are going through it
or have survived and they still call you
and help for help Daniel Baldwin a
couple days ago he's a he's a new man
man he is inspiring oh my god Daniel
Baldwin who are struggling with him now
he's just this great great great guy a
lot of Jenny Ketchum is now a social
worker in Seattle
and married with a baby I mean she was a
porn star when I got we got my hands on
her Steven Adler is doing well there a
lot of them are doing very very very
well in some passed away of opiate
addiction and that's I think people
understand now that the opiate addiction
is fatal and once they got away from me
guess what they went to their pain
doctors pain doctors put them back on
the pain meds they overtook them and
I've seen rise that's that's you know
that's another thing you know I I've
dealt with a lot of chronic pain my
whole life you know if surgery is back
surgery and this and that and I've done
everything you probably can for chronic
pain you know and I'm a I could go on
and I live my life and you know I don't
sit there and constantly complain about
it but I have always these issues I am
always like you know I'm always in pain
never comfortable you know so what do
you say to people who are in chronic
pain something that they can't Vicki is
it you think there's an answer for
everything or sometimes you're just
gonna have to deal with it and that's
just it there's two components of pain
there's Maddock component I get my
finger with a hammer my finger hurts but
there's another piece that's mediated
through a part of the brain called the
insula cortex and the insula is where we
feel essentially or how we feel then
literally how we feel and the insula
sort of registers the misery component
of paint or what we call the effective
charge of pain and in people with
chronic pain that are other usually
people with severe chronic pain or
dysregulated because of trauma and
they're insula cortex goes off and one
of the unfortunate realities is that
opiates make that even a more powerful
reaction where it's just now
overwhelmingly miserable all the time
and gets worse the more and the longer
you exposed to opiates in addition in
addition to causing more misery you
actually develop something called
hyperalgesia where the inexperience of
the somatic component is intensified as
well so it's the worst possible
combination opiates are not a good
treatment for chronic pain so the the
other the kinds of interventions that do
work are more in the sort of neuro
biofeedback zone and the multiple
modality old-fashion pain management my
uncle was the first president of the
American Academy of pain medicine and I
used to go consult at his pain unit
which was physical therapists
biofeedback
psychologists psychotherapists
psychiatrist internist so just multiple
multiple modalities each kind of going
in and try to adjust this essentially
experience and make it more tolerable
for people right because I definitely in
one that you know I don't touch touch
drugs in acupuncturist we all kind of
yeah yeah it all kinds things and it's
hard to predict what's gonna work for a
given individual and Stanford right now
I think that's a pretty good job they're
they're paying program who would you
call if you were if you were suffering
from chronic pain you just wanted to
make sure you've covered all the bases
like you know I think I would make sure
I went to a comprehensive
multidisciplinary pain program something
like this thing on for pain unit and you
go in there and you tell them everything
you've done everything you're working on
the pain how long and all that stuff and
they will sort of slowly just evaluate
you and prod because for me I think it's
been process of eliminations like how do
I get rid of that we have all kinds of
interesting you know techniques and some
of them into mindfully zone and some of
it all kinds of stuff I've done
everything I didn t MDR I mean that
helped it didn't help for that but at
least nothing makes it go away
that's the reality nothing makes it go
away but it's about making it tolerable
or making a little
inside of you is brought to you by fair
harbor you don't want to leave because
you're probably gonna see me and a pair
of fair harbor swimming trunks I don't
know how I wish I could take a lie
detector test for you folks because I
got these shipped to me last week and I
I'm not kidding
I haven't taken them off fair harbor
replaced all mesh lining and they put in
a super soft built-in boxer-brief liner
that's what I'm wearing now that's why
they're so comfortable and it is softer
than anything you've ever felt before
from swimming to exercising a lounging
and even sleeping you're not gonna take
these shorts off
you're really not you're gonna you're
gonna write me fair harbour shorts are
made from recycled plastic this is
probably the coolest part you know it's
a brother/sister they wanted to save the
environment they saw these plastic
bottles and all this crap coming up and
they're like hey let's do something fair
harbors recycled over 2.5 million
plastic bottles they keep plastic out of
waterways and off beaches these kids are
young in their 20s and they already make
me feel like a failure that's how
amazing this company is they're
brilliant fair Harbor is now offering a
kid's line so the younger guys can say
goodbye to mesh lining to their Arbor
makes products for you to enjoy the
places you love while protecting those
places at the same time it's so simple
20 percent off for everyone listening
right now this second head over to fair
harbour clothing calm fair harbor
clothing calm and use the code inside 20
for 20 percent off that's inside 20 and
say goodbye to mesh lining forever I'm
telling you I mean this even if they
don't stop being my sponsor for some
reason I'm buying this stuff that's how
much I like it
all right this is it this is just a this
has been awesome by the way I could talk
to you forever you're so so easy to talk
to that's why I think it's unlike a lot
of doctors it's just that you're so
personable and you know so much and
you've worked so hard and you work with
so many people and celebrities and non
celebrities and I love having you here
and I've been trying to get you on the
show forever because I just think I
truly think you're an amazing human
being so thank you so these are this is
called shit-talking Rosenbaum this is
from my patrons a lot of people out
there so I just ask you questions you
could you'll have to you know you
shorten your answers or whatever but
you'd be quick with Lisa said
you could be whatever you want Lisa what
was your experience like I'm the masked
singer are they really that secretive oh
my god yes it's so secretive you can't
do anybody that you have to tell you
have to make them sign this very
intensive non-disclosure agreement so so
I mean just let me tell you I you know
you start training well before it all
goes down
and only my wife and my manager
publicist knew and they all had to sign
non-disclosure and a voice coach charge
showing up at my house and one of my
son's was living here with us at the
time and I was like oh yeah I'm gonna
sing at a Dodger game I'm gonna sing the
national anthem I'm just preparing for
it and in the long the way it turned out
I had a vocal a real serious injury of
my vocal cords and I had to get folk we
have and all kinds of people were coming
through you news icarly what's going on
and I go okay sign this I'll tell you
you have to sign up so I had one son
signed up for it when you start
production like when you leave your home
you wear shields and hoodies and gloves
and not one speck of skin can show so
you can't identify your race you're not
allowed to speak until you get out of
your car into your trailer and shut the
door and then the only person you can
speak to is who a producer who comes in
and shuts the door behind them and then
you're allowed to speak otherwise
nothing you have no idea who's around
you you have no idea wanna they pay you
a lot no use if use last you get paid
pretty well if you but if you if you're
like me get kicked off a new dress but
you get a 1 you go one day of I mean
think about it you have to get these
song I must see my problem was I learned
about 20 sort of Sinatra and Buble songs
and then I put the costume on and I was
like oh my god it's a rock eagle I don't
know how to sing rock songs holy [ __ ] so
we had to shuck everything and find a
whole new set of songs learn them then
choreography and fireworks and staging
and it's crazy you get one day of
choreography one dress rehearsal an hour
later you say were you nervous dying
dying
and it's it's intense it's super
intensity and the costume kind of
carries you it's weird you should have
become whatever these characters are and
there is one of the funnest things ever
and a hats off to that production man
that all the elements they manage it's
ridiculous and keeping the secrecy at
the same time oh alright Angie are you
tired of Bert Kreischer and Tom Segura
calling every time they do a podcast do
you think Bert will ever listen to
reason yes
no perfect Leanne P what question do men
and women ask the most when it comes to
intimacy historically can I guess yeah
premature ejaculation for guys well it's
in that zone it is more generally am i
normal am i normal am i big enough is
this right am I too fast am I too slow
and am i normal is sort of they're
worried about their functioning women
also worried about men which I find
ironic what's up with them how they work
how come I don't understand because
forever we've raised men and women to
believe that the motivational priorities
are the same at 19 or 20 or 24 but
they're not they're very different and
so it's it's extremely confusing if
you're not realistically assessing one
another and teaching people about about
these motivational systems that are
going in the brain and ultimately we're
all human but our motivational systems
are very very different at that age
isn't there something that someone says
where you're like yeah that's not normal
no that's not I'm sure I'm sure
right cuz everybody has their sexual
what do you call it mishaps or those
things where you're like you know you're
like I couldn't I couldn't I thought I
was about to have an orgasm and then I
couldn't and then I went limp does that
sound familiar
nothing came out and that's retrograde
ejaculation and that's comment it's not
a big deal but it does need to be looked
at a little bit so there's plenty of
stuff where I'm saying get that looked
into rakin what does dr. drew think of
the effect of quarantine is going to
have on people suffering from addiction
better or worse I think what I'm seeing
I think and again this is the data has
yet to come in yet I think
people are switching to alcohol I think
I'm seeing a really significant upswing
of alcohol right now I've never had
quite so many calls for people was real
out of control alcoholism all of a
sudden and I've noticed that I think the
meth is down
I think the gangs are staying indoors
because of fear of covert and so they're
not distributing as aggressively as they
were so I think meth is down and I think
they're switching to how call and if you
go to the homeless somebody was telling
me this in Venice there's much more
alcohol bottles out on the street and
the homeless are more irritable and
aggressive which is again alcohol well
you know just when you thought being
homeless couldn't be worse yeah well
it's interesting the homeless actually
have very low incidence of Kovach very
low because they're outdoors there's a
study in China where they looked at 318
outbreaks of three or more cases of
two-terminal cases most had three to
five cases 80% were in the home 34% were
in in contained transportation
environments one case of 318 the average
was three to five one case was out of
door and it was a one to one to person
transmission out of doors is clearly a
better environment for people to be in
and indoors so again moving outside if
you like I said you want to have your
friend over sit out of doors where I'm
asked be six feet apart probably just
fine
Oh anxiety Emily asks what advice would
you give to someone who deals with
depression every now and then and who
may not have the financial benefits of
going to a therapist it depends where
you are I mean that there are if you're
in Los Angeles there's something called
the maple center that will has excellent
therapist and they are free if you can't
pay I mean they're most in most areas
have at least prorated services
available for psychotherapy and
sometimes a you know intermittent
depression and whatever's going on there
may not take a lot of visits kind of
tune things up and to make a plan and
things you can even do on your own after
somebody figures out what's going on so
my goodness I mean do you go out to
dinner and spend 50 bucks
that's all it cost to go to therapists
so I don't understand why you wouldn't
do that I'll tell you from experience I
just know I always say exercise is so
important I mean what would you because
I just know that I feel better after I
do it well exercise you know long walks
in classical music have performed
admirably when measured against
antidepressant medication and I have
noticed that with this particular
outbreak I've been really depressed this
whole time and what I don't like is
being unable to see the future I don't
like that I can't plan or see a future
and it's very depressing and I turned it
around by running outside in the Sun
having the sunlight getting the air
getting the exercise made all the
difference in the world for me is there
a vitamin is there something in the way
from depression but is there some kind
of vitamin that you just stand by not
that you're trying to promote it but
something that you should be taking
every day I don't care what who you are
this is the whether it's vitamin D or
vite is there something that you just
there's that one but I'll tell you what
I'm doing okay and and and I will
qualify each one as to whether it's it's
just me hey it's there's a promotion
attached to it or hey we all do this
right clearly vitamin D should be
enhanced in the day of Kovac I I've been
a vitamin D family at some time there
are benefits to getting your vitamin D
levels up well beyond how many
milligrams I take about five thousand
six thousand a day okay summer between
five and ten but even that it's hard to
get it up sometimes I take a
multivitamin not because of the multi
mitem because it has minerals and I do
I'm a big fan of maintaining we don't
get a lot of minerals in our diet many
times and so I'm a fan of maintaining
minerals I do that I'm not saying you
should do that so I'm saying do vitamin
D listen to what I do you can think
about it for yourself the studies on
people that take multivitamin show
fairly consistently that people that
take multivitamins that die before
people who don't take multivitamins
that's that's the science do with what
you would do with you will of that I
take I take vitamin C mostly because I'm
on sort of a
kind of a keto diet and so I don't get a
lot of vitamin C so I take vitamin C I
take I take this project this product
called true Nyugen I do promotion for
them but I 18 months ago was convinced
that any D metabolism is an important
part of Aging it's also something
helpful in people coming off drugs and
alcohol
people get nad infusions and this true
nitrogen enhances your nad metabolism
and Mae Mae Lee the science looks like
it may reduce cell senescence meaning it
might affect aging so I take that
everyday I'm Chris sweaty it also has
some anti can you look great then
whenever somebody says that to me I go I
wonder I wonder if it is maybe let's see
I'm leaving something out there that
fish run you got to make a decision
about there's there's controversy around
that you know what combination you want
but I do take I take fish oil what about
like in terms of inflammation with
eating a lot of red meat and is there a
lot of truth to that know that what
there's truth to is in fact that whole
thing has been really shot down I refer
you to the work of Kate Shanahan who's a
good interviewer she would come in okay
really good chemist she's a family
practitioner she she can tell you really
the important things about nutrition the
things we can know we don't know much
really the things we do now but the one
thing we also know is that central
obesity is inflammatory and one of the
things that we're learning about kovat
is if you have fat across your abdomen
you are one of these people that may get
a cytokine storm and my patients that
had antiphospholipid syndrome insulin
resistance central obesity did very
poorly with kovat so there is all in
other words my hypothesis is they were
already inflamed because of this
inflammatory oregon we call adipose
across the central part of their body
that does seem to be true kovat is
reinforcing that fact now meat is not
the mediator of that how much red meat
should i have dr. Kate thought together
I'm not I'm not a nutritionist this is
just what I do I mean I believe at this
point in my life that the carbohydrate
story is a much more
serious story particularly for people
with metabolic syndrome like myself and
and I again all the people that did with
poorly with kovat ate too many
carbohydrates I mean the carbohydrate
problem insulin resistance I think that
may be the major story here and not me
wow this has been fantastic you know so
let me just so where we could find you
and listen to you because you're always
full of so much knowledge the dr. drew
podcast correct it's not my website dr.
calm dr. Joe calm
we're daily stream where we just sort of
go over what's going on with the Cova
thing and answer your questions on
sundays we do a call-in show with guests
and then i do an adamant do a show that
and Carolla how is that being back with
them we've been doing seven years I
think or eight years so really flip out
on each other is there every time we
like just shut the [ __ ] up Adam well I
would say what is it that bothers you
what is it that fires you up when he
says so what is it is it the cynicism or
is it what is it I told him he goes he
goes do I have any you know he was
asking me to be critical of him and I
said Adam you have a blind spot around
aggression he can be very aggressive
sometimes the point where you can't
respond because he's so aggressive and
then he gets mad at you for not
responding so I don't like that find iid
the aggression you know he'll just
become extremely aggressive where you
just you kind of please and I don't like
that is that something that just
happened that approach I mean your god
that's pretty
mild-mannered I mean I'm sure you lose
your shed I have happening like you have
sure I haven't seen you lose your shed
no not publicly probably last time I
lost my [ __ ] was about three years ago
and I just got on a keto diet and you
can get kind of aggressive I think from
that diet and I went and somebody was
trying to get me to do something that I
didn't think was right and I really lost
it on her she was a friend of mine and I
hung up and I did call Bango I am so
sorry I had to go on a like an apology
tour it was not not right not me well
your human world him
thank you I can't thank you enough for
this this has been a blast I really
because that you know I don't really
interview doctors so I sort of knew you
but I was like you know I've been on his
shows and this and that but I you know I
just once we got talking you're so easy
to talk to and I think that's uh that's
just that's it's a rarity that's a great
quality you have I want to thank you for
allowing to be inside of you there you
go all right well thank you again and
open invitation uh amazed by the folks
are gonna just love this they've been
bit should do something that's once more
clarity comes with this Koba thing maybe
we should update update our priors as
they say I would love it I would love it
I am deeply humbled honor this whole
thing is to check my humility always be
humble
yeah well that you are so thank you and
uh I am that's it really
you know that's weird cuz when you're
zooming there's always that moment where
you're like alright goodbye and then you
just sit there for three seconds while
you're sitting okay
shouldn't be a code word like alright
just turn the other way don't look at me
zoom out zoom out all right I'm gonna
switch you off and I'm gonna go and I
appreciate you letting me have to be on
the show and hopefully we'll you me and
Jason or go out and get you know get
bourbon somewhere or something I'd love
that
all right dr. drew right yeah I want to
thank my my my guest dr. drew who's
fantastic hopefully you guys got
something out of it let me know you know
hello at inside of podcast.com if you
have any thoughts or if you have any
comments I try to look at them as much
as possible also the online store inside
of you store we have some inside of you
online store new black hoodies inside of
you my face on it
oh boy black new black shirts with my
face on it and gray and yellow that are
really dope so three new shirts and
thanks to Brandi Edie and they're really
amazing I think you'll like them and
they're selling people really like them
that's cool I want to say thank you
again to my inside you patrons I do it
all the time
you know I love you and I appreciate you
what a fantastic community if you want
to join patreon inside of your podcast
and the other patron which is brand-new
it's only about two weeks old is the Jon
Heder Michael Rosenbaum patron it's only
on patreon and it's a horror movie
patreon it's aware of all the good
horror movies gone so join us on that
there's some really great tears and
things and John's very personable and
amazing and we have a great time it's
early in the game and we're we're
evolving we have a new system of rating
movies it's the rose and bomb rating so
it's there's it's a rose one two three
roses three roses being great or if it's
a bomb Rosenbaum then it gets you know
and right in the middle is a heater a
heater a baseball fan you know it's a
heater right down the middle it's
neither here nor there it's not good
it's not bad I don't care it's the
heater so join us on that too
so thank you real quick shout out to all
the patrons top-tier patrons here you go
and I love that you stick around with me
and hang out I always think you're gonna
you're gonna ditch me which is
understandable you know who you are
Nancy D Mary B Leah s Trisha F CeraVe
Yuki cool it was fun talking to you Kiko
last week Jill E Brian H Brian many of
these people I noticed their patrons on
both the horror patron and the inside of
you unbelievable
unbelievable Lauren G Nikko P barielle
Angelina G Gerry W Kevin R Emily K Bob
be Robert B I want to say your last name
because they know them all now Jason W
Kristen K Andrew see Alison LJ Cindy
Raja
Sean John Sean P Sean W Sean sorry Sean
W Joshua D Emily s cjp rocks racoon
Samantha M Hamza be Jennifer n Stacy B
Carly T Vanessa in the sky ream Jennifer
s 10lb Janelle are as well many of you
neil w tabitha 272 kimberly e melissa
see melissa see
Jake Emrys and Katherine em jackass
jackass I love you jack
Carly asked Judit romera Chris F Sarah f
JW Leanne P Darla W Jackie P Rodrigo s
raishin rach in 7-7 rush on seven seven
I'm going to continue to miss your name
up Travis beer a a Maya P welcome Megan
D Demario Tina J Jennifer see Maddie s
and Tiffany now I'm blessed I'm blessed
I think we're all blessed okay I'm gonna
read some fan mail now this one's from
Katie and it's quicken to the point I
really enjoy your podcasts lost my
husband just over eight months ago
sorry every day has a new meaning he we
it wasn't good
I have way more to say just [ __ ] late
now up here in BC thank
dressing some hard essential issues we
all face day in and day out I appreciate
all of your content it gives me hope you
know it's funny it's like sometimes I
read these and I could feel what she's
saying but she didn't say a ton she said
enough and Kati you know I'm it's so
hard not to say so it's hard to find
something creative to say are different
to say that other than I'm sorry and I
really am sorry and I want you to stay
strong I just want you to give yourself
a break and I want you to find a way to
enjoy life and as I said it before I'm
not the smartest guy in the world but as
far as we know we we only get one so
tomorrow's a new day
we got to get out of bed you know we got
to go for a walk we got to figure it out
we'll figure it out Katie thank you for
your your kind letter thank you again
thank you to all the patrons thank you
for joining me on my Instagram lives
stage it tomorrow at 6 p.m. Pacific time
that's me and Rob Danson where I played
a cup of covers Cup a couple of couple
of peppers we're gonna play a couple of
covers we're gonna play maybe if you
left on Laurel songs maybe an original
or two we'll see what happens it's gonna
be fun there's me prizes and reminding
you guys just to be healthy stay out of
trouble help your fellow man take it
easy on yourselves you're all special
really and and some more let a fan mail
if you send it to hello at inside of you
podcast calm and I'll try to get to it I
mean you know you can keep them short or
as long as you want I like short and
quickly another shout out to just the
the charities that I love Ronald
McDonald House of Los Angeles the animal
rescue mission echoes of hope for a
foster youth
and that about wraps it up thank you
guys so much for listening and thank you
for letting to be inside you
[Music]